[Music]
the clearest dynamic we have to deal
with as people
thinking about the future of the city is
the polarization of the public
conversation you know the lack of
collective idea of what the city is for
and we think that the streets
that kind of gigantic untapped resource
of open space in cities really
is a place where we can really work to
transform something that's been reserved
for
motor cars into something that's an
amenity for the whole population
hopefully in a way that can be scalable
to the whole country and beyond
[Music]
as countries wonder how to meet their
carbon neutral promises
many have also begun to question the
future of our cities
a popular model is the 15-minute city
it's a vision of a decentralized urban
area where your daily needs are within a
quarter
hour walk or bike from your home it
promises to cut greenhouse emissions
and boost livability but while paris
works on neighborhoods with a 15-minute
radius
and barcelona explores a similar idea
dividing areas into nine block chunks
sweden is taking the hyper-local concept
one step
further
the one minute city idea of course uses
a buzzy sounding phrase to talk about
the
even more local than the hyper local
scale you know the street
exactly outside your front door or
outside the door of a
cafe or a business and how that can be
transformed to make
additional amenity space to make public
spaces that
didn't exist before this is the street
moves project
and it allows communities to become
architects of their own streets layouts
it's led by two national government
agencies arcdes
the national center for architecture and
design and vinova
the swedish government's national
innovation agency
i think there's a sort of implicit
critique in the project that questions
residents and citizens role in planning
processes
we have now these very large scale
formal planning processes in most
western countries that make it very hard
for individual citizens to
influence the outcome of urban change
but we know that citizens have really
really strong opinions especially about
their immediate environment so that
method of involving citizens with their
hyper-local
extremely expert knowledge on their
environment but getting that out of
their heads and putting out on the table
for
for designers but also for agencies
national agencies and municipalities we
think there's something really really
valuable in that
[Music]
unlike the 15-minute city concept the
street moves model isn't about offering
every feature of a city at a hyper-local
level
instead it turns patches of pavement
outside our front doors
into critical connecting spaces for
communities
through workshops and consultations
residents can control how much street
space is used for parking
and how much is used for anything else
they can think of
it's already been rolled out
experimentally at four sites in
stockholm
with three more cities about to join up
the prototypes were designed by lundberg
design an industrial design
firm here in in stockholm and the the
prototype that exists is a kind of
deployable
system which runs on three simple tracks
which can easily be laid down on the
street
and then sort of cassettes or sections
of timber are laid on top of them
and those sections they fit together and
create a kind of boardwalk
which can be leveled with the pavement
of course
and different kind of elements can can
be integrated into them be it seating
opportunities for planting cycle storage
electric scooter storage
and later many many other things
when you make something in three
dimensions by a designer who's skilled
at
making something beautiful intriguing
different in a in a material in this
case that's not often seen on the
streets in timber
it becomes a talking point sweden has
committed its cities to becoming carbon
neutral by 2045
making a project like street moves that
de-emphasizes car use
more of a feasible prospect but that's
not all that street moves wants to
address
of course the transformation that needs
to come to our cities
because of the need to decrease our
carbon use
is the most urgent driver for all of the
transformations that are coming
especially in swedish cities
but we use that cover sometimes and we
use that huge
undeniable momentum to also have other
conversations and i think it's no
accident and no coincidence
that alongside the ecological driven
transformation that's coming
there's also a socially driven one be it
black lives matters
be it me too be it large-scale
citizen-led movements
that are bringing new dynamics in the
public conversation that creates new
demands for the city and i think
everybody's starting to realize you know
the ecological transformation
that needs to come is just as much a
cultural project as it is technical
street moves ultimate goal is ambitious
to rethink and make over
every street in sweden over the next
decade
[Music]
but while this kind of grand
transformation might appear to only work
for a country like sweden
long and the street moves team are
confident the concept can cross borders
i think the future of scaling up this
kind of project internationally will be
about
using the talent in those individual
spaces for what they're good at
in sweden we have great skill in
industrial design so that kind of
modularity the materials and so on
really really good at that
in another country it might be a
completely other set of skills you know
it might be that the designers take more
of a lead
on the public conversation than they
might do here in sweden
in the end what i believe in is that the
extraordinary talent that
is around the world in design and
architecture can
play a massively bigger role than it
already does in that public conversation
in generating new ideas for how we use
our city public spaces
[Music]
you